boop sandwich
buff sandwich
[Music]
my name is george moats and my job is to
celebrate the american hamburger
but i'm going to tell you this right now
you get outside the united states people
have done some pretty crazy with
hamburgers let me tell you
got two today the islak from turkey
and the buff sandwich from denmark one
is steamed in tomato sauce basically and
the other one is swimming in a pool of
brown gravy
what do these two burgers have in common
they're both a hot wet mess
so wish me luck did you know how it is
when i get near hot wet stuff
yay you ready let's do this the isla
burger a beloved street food from
istanbul turkey specifically from the
city center in a place called taksim
square toxin square there are street
vendors that sell this wet burger right
from steamed glass boxes on the street
think of kufta middle eastern meatball
that has been
pattied flat and cooked like a hamburger
i've never tasted the isla burger but i
wanted to speak to somebody who has
grown up eating this burger i know a guy
who should definitely know what it
tastes like
dr oz dr oz
how are you thanks for being on burger
skuller sessions what is your connection
to turkey my parents are both turkish my
mom still lives in turkey i've gone
there every year of my life
i spent a ton of time enjoying turkish
cuisine i'm about to make a burger that
i've actually never tasted before but
what is it is isla burger and am i
pronouncing that right do you know what
that is
i do know what it is it's actually said
quite nicely so the word is
means wet it tucks in the little word
literally means to divide because it was
the main place where water was divided
coming into the city there are these
street carts in toxium that have to make
things that turks like and that
westerners like so they have to be a
little flexible and i'll be your taste
buds are you ready for this my best
description
right they're soft the patties are thin
they're very garlicky they melt in your
mouth i mean you literally they drip all
over you as you eat them you know
sometimes hot messes are what you want
in your life this is one of those
versions you just made me so hungry and
i cannot wait to try this burger now
thank you dr us thanks for being on
burger scholar sessions
there's joy i got hungry too let's start
by mixing the beef little cumin
and pepper
parsley a little bit everything in there
spice in the beef
whoa okay well we like spicy right it's
okay
oh
some fresh parsley we're going to grate
an onion in here too
oh
sorry
oh jeez i can't even
sorry it's like i can't even see i'm in
a mess what i'm going to do is make
small balls tiny balls meatballs
oh my god it already smells so good what
the hell is that stuff over there right
exactly
that's what makes the isla burger wet
right there that is pretty basic tomato
sauce
how can you smell that
man
that smells good
if you think about street food street
food has to be
plentiful it has to be quick obviously
right this makes perfect sense because
the vendor could cook a patty
and then let it sit warming in a sauce
and then when a customer came by to get
a burger they could just take it out of
the sauce and serve it to bun let's go
to the next stage
just to get the bun ready hello hello
you take the burger okay
and you stick it into the bun okay there
we go now
put it into the steamer that yay
steam is hot people i want to put
some of the
some of the sauce on top of the burger
this is going to make a freaking mess of
your steamer i'm sorry but just
trust me on this
and let it steam
oh yeah what you doing in there
they're ready hi
[ __ ]
oh yeah
oh there you go
would you please look at this thing oh
so hot
jesus
check it out behold
the turkish wet burger this lock burger
from turkey
mmm tomatoey garlicky
and full
a beautiful middle eastern spice
wow
that is a unique experience oh that one
yum that's a great idea right there
why why the [ __ ] we don't have more of
those in the world
why is this burger limited to only
istanbul i'm confused brother the next
the buff sandwich from denmark
oh hey i'm not done with this though
that's right the buff sandwich also
known as the gravy burger and you'll see
why
now i'm going to tell you something this
is probably one of the most complicated
burgers i've ever had to make this is no
simple cheeseburger at all and by the
way this burger is eaten with a knife
and a fork that's right one of the very
few burgers i will ever eat with a knife
and a fork if you're in france everybody
eats burgers with knives and forks why
do you do that why don't do that it's
ridiculous what are you afraid of i have
good friends in denmark so i called my
friend klaus voutrep who owns gasoline
grill in copenhagen to see what he had
to say about the buff sandwich
what up man
copenhagen
my friend klaus would trip from the
gasoline grill is an american style
hamburger joint in copenhagen would you
call it that yeah i would yeah
definitely american we have
cheeseburgers we have a butter burger
actually oh you do have a
burger yeah so klaus i've only had one
buff sandwich it was not in denmark and
i'm pretty sure it was totally
inaccurate describe what is the taste of
this thing i would like to have a lot of
like
richness and
like roasted dark flavors in the
in the gravy and then all like the
sweetness and also acidity from all the
condiments you put in there i'm so
hungry i can't i cannot wait to eat this
thing yeah i can't wait to see what you
come up with
me too
klaus thank you
good to see you
first i'm gonna make a patty now bush
sandwich
is not a thin smashed patty they
actually use sort of thick patties
one of the most important ingredients
though is the brown gravy you got to get
that right this is a brown pork gravy
that i made from pork stock and pork fat
that's good mmm
good gravy flipping
woof sandwich
this is how they treat the buff sandwich
in denmark they take a perfectly cooked
burger and they dunk it in gravy look at
that
they dug it in beautiful
brown pork
gravy let's start building the burger
pickle beets on the bottom then the
patty look at that
put a dijon mustard unfortunately some
ketchup so it's kind of mixed in with
the
with the mustard it might be okay then a
remoula the remoulade is very important
this is not the remoulade you think of
when you think of louisiana for example
this is a basic french remoulade it's a
lemony
mayo and mustard sauce with dill pickle
chunks in it raw onion sweet
cucumbers which in this case we're using
bread and butter sweet pickles the
grilled onion which they call soft onion
next they dump some gravy on top
yeah but wait one final ingredient
crispy
onions on top
there it is ladies and gentlemen one of
the most complicated burgers i've ever
made
this better be good
boof sandwich
boop sad
now you can't pick this up you have to
use a knife and a fork
that's the rule
have to
this is so weird
this is like driving with my feet or
something this is bizarre i got the
beets i got the the gravy the bun
okay
that's good
but i sure wish i could pick it up
but oh those crispy onions
i could just have crispy onions and
gravy and be happy
looking in here that's it oh what's that
it's a pickle it's an onion
it's a beet
it's a mess
but it is one tasty hot mess
as you can see from this
pile of danish hamburger soup
there's no end
there's no end at all
to what the hamburger can be both
burgers
a hot wet mess
and i love them for this i'll see you
next time when i eat a burger with my
hands
[Music]
hi i'm george moats burger scholar
sessions don't forget to like and
subscribe and watch more episodes right
here
somewhere here
right here
up in here